[Musique]
avec la crise économique est tout le
monde est à la recherche de valeurs
refuge d'investissements rentables
plutôt que de laisser son argent en
banque et prendre le risque de le perdre
en cas de chute des marchés
alors il dit alors évidemment valeur
refuge parmi toutes qui atteint
d'ailleurs des records depuis la
pandémie s'échangeant à plus de 2000
dollars l'once
et puis et on y pense sans doute un peu
moins les pierres précieuses et autres
j'aime
prenons par exemple le diamant déjà il
faut savoir que lorsqu'on achète un
diamant comme n'importe quel bijou la
tva s'applique sur le caillou et bim
c'est déjà 20% de perdus
d'autre part chaque pierre est unique et
se classe selon de nombreux critères son
poids sa forme sa couleur sa pureté sa
qualité de taille
un diamant n'en vaut pas forcément un
autre et lorsqu'on n'y connaît rien ça
peut déboucher sur une arnaque une
revente compliqué et donc un
investissement sacrément risqué
d'ailleurs le marché des diamants peut
parfois aussi plongé pendant la crise
des subprimes selon les échos le prix
des diamants ordinaire a connu une chute
sensiblement identique à celle des
marchés financiers il faut toutefois
savoir également que le diamant sauter
aussi de plus en plus rares au fil des
années en 20 ans sa valeur aurait plus
que doublé et risquent de continuer à
augmenter fortement durant les années
qui viennent
retour j'ai trouvé une grosse planète
bleue je veux voir ce que c'est